oh I
[Music]
see
oh hi it's been recording this whole
time welcome back to welcome back to
Buckshot roulette you remember how last
time I asked if there was a hard mode
well there is it's actually called
double or nothing mode but since I
was I think good at this game I'm going
to try this again and I'm going to try
the hard mode
because it worked out nicely for me
before so I don't see how it could go
wrong
now there's also a few other things that
I think are part of this but the hard
mode is this remember how I saw the
pills there before
[Music]
whoa
sure always a good idea to take some
random pills that you
see in a club
bathroom
all right whatever we got we got book
shot to book we got shot to book hi
hello man your face is unsettling you
got it um I heard there was an Easter
egg if I
do
[Music]
that nice all
right
oh maybe not wait a minute but I don't
want my name to be devil that's
dumb that's that's
[Music]
dumb why AR you talking to me oh let's
see what happens I'm I'm going to I'm
hold on hold on I just I just want to
you know give it give a little bit up
get a bit hi welcome back to Buckshot
roulette remember last time when I said
if there was a ask if I asked if if if
hi welcome back to Buckshot roulette
we're going to take some pills okay so
this is double or nothing mode and I'm
not going to be called the devil cuz
that would be dumb who would do that so
uh probably not any Easter eggs with the
names who was there did someone lie to
me I don't even know well that's
unhelpful okay
yeah oh I get
more that doesn't seem
[Music]
right wait a minute that's that's a
little different than my memory doth
[Music]
say I wasn't looking at the shells all
right let's see what happens take one of
these all
right well that's what you
get you know it's a shame that happens
to your face so early you were just so
delightful
otherwise
[Music]
uhhuh you know I half expected that to
go
off the
freck
the
what you know I don't 100% understand
what was going on there but hey you know
it's fine I guess
all right it's a dud
hey look over
me and now look over
you wow that is a lot of
[Music]
blood Dash me baby so I don't know what
double or nothing really means if that
can go on endlessly oh that's it
that's
it you know if Luck's on my side then
this could be over real
quick I've got my fingers
crossed
hi
oh hey
he
yeah all right oh oh yeah that that
happens that's fine man I think this
might be the fastest anyone's ever
gotten to round
three you know if I was a speedrunner
I'd be doing really good right now hey
brusi oh I
see I like those odds wait a minute why
do you get a knife and I get a
beer
let's see what
happens all right the odds are in my
favor let's see what happens
ha
oo all right well I got a long way to
go yeah I knew you're going to do that
but the question is what are you going
to do after that try me
all right well fine then two can play at
that game what are the odds that there's
one of these and one of this also how
can I climb back from this there been
two one two buckle my
shoe haha all right now watch one of
these cuz it's about to get real spicy
all up in your
nose that's what I'm talking about
up so what are you going to do huh fool
yeah all
right and that's it for that but we got
more so how many items do I get this
time oh it must be
uhoh well that that's not good that's
that's not good all right so this is
where the conundrums kick in right cuz I
don't know it's 50/50 it's been 50/50
this whole time I'm assuming the pill
mode is like hard mode so it's really
just a roll of the dice and how Hefty
your sack is in this particular day my
sack's real Hefty I mean it doesn't
matter if I do this now or
later but what I need to do is I need to
make
sure that I save my item for later
because watch one of these I bet you
thought this was going to KY my nog
didn't so we've tried our luck we put
the odds a little more in the
favor let's just see what
happens
hi all right so you uh yeah I knew that
was going to happen now that was
obvious and I knew that was going to
happen that was
obvious interesting
well I don't know what the wisdom of his
Maneuvers are because it doesn't seem
like they're very
wisdom okay see I feel like if you you
point it at yourself all
right all right now I got to I got to
make sure I got
this oh good thing I made sure all right
excuse me look over my
shoulder m M made you
[Music]
look oh yeah oh yeah double or nothing I
think yes give me some of that
money I'm ready for more oh you got to
go all the way around
again that's fine I can do that
yes
hey why does he get
[Music]
some all
right okay I got my strategy take one of
these I'm not going to use a handcuff
right off the bat because I knew that
was going to happen well I didn't know
that was going to happen but I had a
good feeling about that's going to
happen that's the same as knowing so
he's going to do that but the thing is
there's now three blanks in there it
puts me me in a better perspective I
would have loved for that to occur then
you better not oh you better
not all right if he gets
lucky yeah yeah I know I know I
[Music]
know oh man see that's not cool man that
that better blast you God damn it you
lucky son of a
didn't even need the handcuffs do I get
to keep them I feel like I should be
able to keep those if I rationed my
goodies see that's not
fair anyway I knew that his hubris would
get to him
so speaking of
hubris it's the first time it's been a
different number number all right well I
better smoke these up because this is
going to get dicey I don't know if these
go over the number oh crap well he can
basically finish me off in one go so I
don't know how that's going to go if I
can't go
over
[Music]
uh B Bob Boo b Bob okay here's what we
do this is what I should have done man I
had the cigarettes there I should have
saved them all right whatever
um
keep
those so
honorable all right so this is what
we're going to
do we're going to do
this oh that's
unfortunate that's really unfortunate
yeah yeah I I know I know well it's it's
it's not going to hold on hold on just
yeah hold on okay so yeah I don't think
that that should have
counted you see how I don't think that
should have counted right
so what's unfortunate now is that
there's two lives and four blanks which
is truly unfortunate because now his
handcuffs are not in play I misplayed
this a bit but I know when I'm doing
good trust me this is the right Strat
this is the right
strategy trust me on this one cuz here's
the thing here's what I'm going to do
you're trusting me on this
one oh wait a minute see okay that
that ain't fair
oh oh oh oh waste your waste it oh
man I can't believe that worked cuz I
just needed to get out of that item
environment there's nothing left in
[Music]
there all right so I may have flubbed it
last time but this time I've got this
fascinating that's a lot of that's a lot
of
those
[Music]
interesting so what I need to do is I
just need to make him not have that
yep okay blank all right just going to
do it
[Music]
again damn I was hoping it would be the
other way around but this is
fine around again you know you get real
hesitant God damn what damn
damn interesting all right I need I just
need him to get gone y cuz otherwise
he's he's going to handcuff me to Helen
back I got to get okay so what I need to
do is I need to check because now
there's two Reds one blank so if I look
in and it's a blank rack it cut it it's
a blank good thing I did that rack
[Music]
it cut it and boom it's
game this one went on a little bit
longer you prick but take one of
these I win I
win I
win all right come on come on let's see
this come
on we're still going baby we're still
going oh
interesting nice
okay
three okay Even
Stevens all right it would be really
good if the first one was blank but if
it's not and I hit myself and he gets
another one then it's not really good
for me no matter what I need to hit him
once and then definitely with the knife
this is the right move CU if it's not
no M okay it's a blank I should have
counted on that
whoops oh god oh thank
goodness this guy is bold he's bold he's
not smart but he's certainly bold it was
two blanks and uh
alive so depending on what this
says so it's a blank so I just need
to so that means that's that's the last
of the blanks it's game over huh this
guy you
know yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah all
right take one
of
pleas wait what hold the
phone wait
he racked it my first one was a blank he
racked
it and that was a blank and then he shot
himself he drank a beer racked it shot
himself that was not a blank I looked in
it was a blank it was three and
three what did I miscount somewhere it's
three and three it was exact it was
pretty much exactly like that there yeah
whatever well this isn't going to go
well for me let's see what I lose
out damn it damn it all right don't be
two in a
row thank
goodness all right let's just hope for
the
best I swear I swear wasn't it just
three
oh did I do the thing where did I look
at it and not no I didn't look at it it
was it was a shotgun or it was a
beer well this is this is bad I'm I
think I'm doomed there I I
swear I swear that that's what that
was oh boy well this is not going to be
good oh never
mind that's very confusing and also I
was not counting here so I don't
remember cuz I was so flabbergasted
about what occurred before that I've
kind of Forgotten what's there so I it
was three and three racked he racked one
I hit a blank it should still be 50/50
so if I don't get this it's a blank and
it's fine so I better do
this all right I don't know what was
with weird counting there that got way
too close but we're all
[Applause]
good
hell yeah I want a double or nothing
should
I yeah all right I better learn to count
if I'm going to get through this again
yoink yoink yoink wow thank
you why do you get four wait a minute
that's not fair okay that's three and
three you're not going to change it on
me are
you all
right blank
okay I really hope really hope that the
next one is not a
blank the odds would uh not be in my
[Music]
favor the only benefit being that he
wouldn't be able to look in take one of
these
oh oh that's
nice well let's see if it's Even Stevens
because if it's not even Stevens ooh
that's not even
Stevens
he only has
[Music]
cigarettes all right here's the thing I
like these
odds never
mind all right I didn't like the odds
that
much okay if this I swear to God okay
that's what I was thinking that's what I
was thinking all
right I like these odds
I like these odds oh my goodness okay
well okay if this isn't the shell then
it's a
blank so I should just hold him to
it or I should save them and let's see
what
happens hey that worked out nicely cuz
the next one is a
blank he yeah smoke them while you got
them I still got got a pair of handcuffs
that I didn't waste cuz I'm big and
smart and my brain is too big too
huge and
[Music]
whatever all right well I'm in luck cuz
I got the goods ooh that's nice oh you
got ply okay four and four all right I'm
going to keep track of it this time
don't you worry about that so what I
need to do is not give him an
opportunity to do anything he's got
those those smokes which is
unfortunate so the trick that I got to
do is I got to get him in one turn which
is what the handcuffs are for I got to
get him one turn because it's not going
to be this one no matter what I do but I
can't give him more than one opportunity
to shoot me because I'm not going to get
around to another round where I have
cigarettes so what I need to do is I
need to take this hit if it's going to
be a hit no matter what I can take one
hit so I might as well roll the dice
that this is going to be for him it's
not that's okay because now there's four
red and
three two blue there's four red
oh okay well that's
okay yeah I know careful now okay so
this is this is
tricky but what I'm going to count on so
there's three red two blue so what I
need to do is I need to hold him to this
chances are
that this is going to be in there
there's no guarantee if I don't get this
it's kind of game
[Music]
over o needed
that all right so that was
two two
shoots two blanks
three blanks wait two
shoots this could be
bad I'm going to Rack
it just in case that was only two shoots
please don't be a shoot yes okay please
finish this
guy oh freak oh freak well it's okay
he's really dumb everybody keep this in
mind he's very
dumb
he might not be that
dumb all right here's a tricky
bit I believe it's one in
one but I ain't going to go out pointing
that at myself if I lose here it's
because I pointed it at
him oh oh oh
oh oh my
goodness that's nice that's real nice
did I get a little too excited probably
not handcuffs
knives four all right four and four I'm
actually going to count this
[Music]
time
he ding dong ding dong ding dong why is
it your turn I feel like if you get shot
it's my turn no that doesn't make any
sense this guy in his
cigarettes okay Two Reds one blue down
so there's three blues Two
Reds there's two Blues Two
Reds holy there's one blue Two Reds
yeah keep it up
buddy I don't understand that it's one
in one somehow I'm going to save these
items cuz somehow it's gone down to one
in one I don't know how that happened
but this guy had a crazy streak uh well
it's okay I can take that that hit
I'd rather keep the items for then the
next batch when I get more items oh
no thank God you got a defibrillator for
my
face all
right
oh I am very so whoa interesting
[Music]
fascinating well I'm going to Rack
it
F by me more items I am going to finish
this guy into Oblivion you
go prepare for the end of
[Music]
times oh
nice two and two a man that's extra
spicy
yep I like those odds
[Music]
let's see what
happens
dealer
oh oh
interesting
fascinating now it's two
shooties oh you can't double up on those
ooh that's interesting it doesn't want
you to double up
anymore
fascinating oh this would be truly
unfortunate if I somehow turned this
around and didn't get it well can only
do what I can do let's hope that he
points it at himself even if he looks at
it look at
[Music]
this all right so he's got some smokes
which is
unfortunate but he can't do double
damage unless he well you can't
actually cuz I don't know that hand
handcuffs carry
through into the other round I hope that
he wastes all his items up oh
interesting
no all right well unfortunately that
didn't go according to plan but that's
okay cuz plans were always meant to fail
interesting interesting
interesting three and four fascinating
here
interesting okay all I got to
do three and four I'm going rack
[Music]
it that's interesting that's not what I
would have expected so it's now two and
four four blue two red odds
are you got to be ballsy at some point
here take this that's what I thought
okay now there's three blue two red I
could take a page out of his book and
just keep pointing it at myself but that
doesn't seem like the smart thing to do
so I'm going to do the really dumb thing
to
do you ready for this this is going to
be really dumb you ready for
dumb
okay now see that didn't take any of the
handcuffs so this is where the smartness
comes
[Music]
in
[Applause]
God
damn no you see I'm smart I just went
through three rounds of that and I won
you give me my money I'm going home I'll
see you around buddy boo have fun with
all those bullet wounds I'm going to
walk home with a giant briefcase of cash
thank you very much let meink in aink
and you s
crant
wow and that's how you win at Buckshot
roulette cuz if there's one thing that I
do let's
win thank you that's
me oh yeah that's what I'm that's a lot
of beer but that's
okay nice nice maybe next time I'll try
for a Millie maybe next time I'll not
play this have a good one thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye